all this week on eight news now you've
been watching our 8 news now
investigation into the California Water
Hogs and tonight we're looking at some
of the commendable things those water
hogs in California do to conserve water
eight news now investigator Kyle Payne
is here with more
this week we aired a four-prong
investigation into water use in
California and found what they're doing
and what they aren't doing in the areas
of water storage irrigation Recycling
and desalinating tonight we give
California the last word and they say
they're doing more there than we here
might think
the more we can spread the word to kind
of correct that perception of Southern
California as the villain and we're
doing just as much as as you know
Arizona Nevada Nevada and Arizona might
not agree but La Department of Water and
Power Manager of water resources policy
Terence McCarthy is bullish on the steps
his department is taking to tackle the
Water Crisis on the Colorado River
there's some new stuff that we're doing
new stuff like a Turf replacement rebate
for people who tear out their lawn in
favor of sustainable Landscapes
assessments of commercial properties to
help identify where they can save water
and financial assistance for commercial
owners to encourage them to upgrade
their systems and just like in Las Vegas
they have water cups on the hunt to
crack down on people who are misusing
their water and as a whole people in La
have reduced their water consumption by
30 percent over the last 15 years
they're more the helping hand than they
are than they are the police but in LA
La they're most proud of their safe
clean water program which the voters
there passed giving the county hundreds
of millions of dollars to recycle reuse
recapture and divert water all part of
an overall Suite of actions to add to
our water supply reliability Bill
hazenkamp manages Colorado River
resources for the Metropolitan water
district which supplies water to 19
million Southern Californians we can't
just stay in the same path we've been on
the last three decades and that's why in
La they're trying to keep up with the
conservation efforts around here we are
working towards that and and if if not
on par with Southern Nevada Water
Authority very close to where to where
their programs are even with all that
good California says they're doing
they're not playing nice with the other
six Basin States California is the loan
holdout on renewing the seven State
agreement on water rights they even
wanted Phoenix and Las Vegas cut off
from the water supply before la
foreign